les anges il est mon vote
une fois qu'on sait ce que c'est les
algériens ont adopté une expression pour
désigner leur chef d'état le président
jean bie depuis son accident vasculaire
cérébral survenu en 2013
abdelaziz bouteflika n'a pas pris la
parole en public
on le dit un physique est largement
paralysé j'ai ajouté laurence hahn
insultes quoi c'est mettre le met de
l'huile sur le feu c'est aux français
consomment anciens combattants de
l'indépendance
abdelaziz bouteflika avait commencé sa
carrière politique en lion en 1963 il
devient le plus jeune ministre des
affaires étrangères du monde
il a 26 ans il restera à ce poste
jusqu'à la fin des années 1970
il est ensuite accusé de corruption et
s'exile pendant plusieurs années comme
le rappelle ce professeur dhc à montréal
il a trempé dans le détournement ce que
l'on appelait le trésor du fln le trésor
du front de libération nationale
bouteflika revient pourtant en algérie à
la fin des années 1990 et trouve le
moyen de rehausser lentement sa cote de
popularité
je n'ai pas soutien massif du peuple
algérien je considère qu'il doit être
dans sa meilleure qualité bouteflika est
élu président pour la première fois en
1999 au terme de la décennie noire qui
aurait fait jusqu'à 150 mille morts
il accorde l'amnistié inconditionnelle
au tueur et trouve le moyen d'améliorer
les conditions de vie d'une partie de la
population selon omar un taux d'accès au
logement l'accès aux voitures aux
produits électroménagers etc rapporté en
masse et si vous mentionnez quoi je
dirais même
très sensiblement parvis monty rabat
j'ai le devoir et la volonté d'apaiser
le coeur et les esprits de mes
compatriotes
aujourd'hui le message du candidat
bouteflika ne semble plus convaincre les
manifestations populaires se poursuivent
tandis que collectif d'artistes
algériens parmi les plus connues vient
de produire une chanson de protestation
contre les régimes sylvain desjardins
radio canada
[Musique]
qui